TAKING ABOUT A FOURTH BILL, AND
PROXY VOTING.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY.
IT’S ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I WANT TO GET STARTED TO THE
LETTER YOU SENT TO THE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI TO TRY TO GET HER
TO PUSH BACK ON THIS PROXY
VOTING AS WELL AS TO ENSURE THAT
CERTAIN KEY COMMITTEES COME BACK
TO WORK.
TELL US ABOUT THE LETTER YOU
SENT HER AND THE RESPONSE YOU’VE
GOTTEN?
>> WELL I SENT A LETTER TO HER
LAST WEEK.
SHE WANTED TO CHANGE 200 YEARS
OF HISTORY SO CONSTITUENTS LEND
THEIR VOICE TO THEIR
CONGRESSWOMAN OR  CONGRESSMAN
FOR TWO YEARS WANT TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE BUT NANCY PELOSI
WANTS TO DO WITH CONGRESS IS TO
BE ABLE TO HOLD 200 PROXIES, 200
DIFFERENT VOTES FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO MAKE HER MORE
POWERFUL CONTROL THE FLOOR.
FORTUNATELY AFTER MY LETTER AND
OUR DISCUSSION WITH HER SHE HAS
PULLED BACK ON THAT, BUT
CONGRESS IS ESSENTIAL.
WE HAVE WORKED THROUGH THE CIVIL
WAR, WORLD WAR II AND OTHERS.
WE NEED TO GET TO WORK AND JUST
AS STATES WOULDN’T OPEN UP
COMPLETELY AT ONCE WE NEED
COMMITTEES TO COME BACK IN, LIKE
ARMS SERVICES TO DO THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE BILL.
YOU HAVE APPROPRIATE OR S MAKING
SURE GOVERNMENT IS FUNDED.
YOU COULD BRING OVERSIGHT BACK
TO LOOK AT THE WHO AND THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IS
ACTING NOT LIKE THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION BUT MORE LIKE THE
WUHAN HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
WE SHOULD ACTUALLY GET THE FACTS
AND THE ANSWERS AND THOSE
COMMITTEES COULD COME BACK
WITH NOT THE ENTIRE CONGRESS TO
SHOW THAT WE ARE WORKING FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC JUST AS
WE WATCH THESE STATES PHASE
IN AND A SAFE, HEALTH IT MANNER.
MARIA: BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT SHE
WANTS RIGHT?
SHE WANTS EVERYONE TO NOT COME
BACK UNTIL MAY?
AND IS THAT RIGHT?
AND IS THAT THE PLAN?
THAT IS THE CURRENT PLAN BUT
AFTER MY CONVERSATION WITH THE
SPEAKER, SHE PUT TOGETHER
THREE REPUBLICANS AND THREE
DEMOCRATS, MYSELF AND THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND OTHERS
TO START WORKING ON PLANNING ON
HOW WE CAN DO THIS.
I DON’T THINK YOU SHOULD CHANGE
THE HISTORY OF HOW CONGRESS
VOTES TO EMPOWER ONE SIDE.
CONGRESS CAN WORK, WE JUST
PROVED IT.
WE HAVE PASSED SOME OF THE
BIGGEST BILLS IN THE HISTORY
OF CONDITIONING RESEARCHER
DURING THIS PANDEMIC, WE CAN
OPEN UP IN A MANNER AND HAVE
COMMITTEES WORKING THAT CAN WORK
IN BIGGER BUILDINGS SO THEY HAVE
SOCIAL DISTANCING, THEY CAN DO
IT IN A SAFE MANNER WHILE ALL
THE MEMBERS AREN’T THERE AND WE
CAN HAVE PRODUCT BEING WORKED
FOR THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
MARIA: WHY IS THE SPEAKER NOW
TALKING ABOUT NOVEMBER ELECTIONS
MUST GO ON.
SHE SAYS THE PRESIDENT MAY TRY
TO POSTPONE IT.
HOW CAN WE ENSURE A SAFE
ELECTION AND LET’S TALK A BIT
ABOUT CHINA.
THAT HAS CERTAINLY BEEN THE
DOMINANT STORY BUT A NUMBER
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES COMPLETELY
MISSED CHINA AS A THREAT AS THEY
CONTINUE TO INVESTIGATE RUSSIA
AND THE GHOSTS OF COLLUSION.
THIS ISN’T THE BEGINNING OF
NANCY PELOSI THE SPEAKER TALKING
ABOUT NOVEMBER’S ELECTIONS.
SHE BROUGHT THIS UP AND HELD UP
THE FIRST CARES ACT OF MORE THAN
$2 TRILLION.
THIS IS WHEN SHE WANTED TO
INSTITUTE CHANGE ELECTION LAW,
GO FOR THE GREEN NOW DEAL, PAY
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
FOR  EVERY MOMENT THESE DEMOCRAT
S HAVE TRIED TO HELD UP
EACH BILL TO PLAY POLITICS WITH
IT AND I EXPECT HER TO CONTINUE
THE SAME BUT WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION AND NOT TRY TO GIVE
ADVANTAGE TO ONE PARTY OR  THE
OTHER, BUT MAKE SURE
THEY’RE FAIR.
YOU ARE CORRECT, MARIA, YOU WERE
ONE OF THE FIRST THAT WAS
SHOWING WHAT CHINA WAS DOING.
I REMEMBER TWITTER PEOPLE ON
TWITTER CRITICIZING YOU BECAUSE
YOU WERE ONE OF THE FIRST ONES
COMING OUT THERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LABORATORIES IN WUHAN.
CONCERNED ABOUT WAS CHINA BEING
HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
NOW WE SEE OWN STUDY BY SOUTH
HAMPTON THAT HAD CHINA BEEN
HONEST WITH THE WORLD 95% OF
THIS NEVER WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
WHAT CHINA HAS DONE HAS DIRECTLY
LED TO AMERICANS DEATH AND THIS
IS WHERE WE SHOULD HAVE
STARTED LONG AGO AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS BEEN CORRECT ABOUT
CHINA LONG BEFORE WHEN HE WAS
JUST A CANDIDATE ABOUT OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN, WITH REGARDS TO
OUR PHARMACEUTICALS, CRITICAL
MINERALS AND OTHERS AND ONE
THING WE SHOULD LEARN FROM THIS
PANDEMIC IS NEVER PUT
OURSELVES IN THIS POSITION AGAIN
LOOK WHAT JAPAN IS DOING.
JAPAN IS PULLING BACK THOSE
COMPANIES FROM CHINA.
WE SHOULD DO THE SAME.
OUR ALLIES COULD AS WELL AND WE
CAN MAKE THE WORLD STRONGER AND
NEVER BE IN THE SITUATION AGAIN.
MARIA: YEAH, YOU MAKE A GREAT
POINT, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE PRESIDENT COMPLETELY CHANGED
THE CONVERSATION ON CHINA.
WILL THERE BE A FOURTH STIMULUS
PACKAGE, CONGRESSMAN?
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR IN
TERMS OF PUTTING IN ANOTHER
RELIEF BILL EVEN AS , EVEN
MCCONNELL, YOUR COLLEAGUE ON THE
SENATE, IS QUESTIONING THE
DEBT.
NOW THE DEBT THAT THIS COUNTRY
FACES IS HIGHER THAN THE ACTUAL
SIZE OF THE ECONOMY,
$22 TRILLION.
>> THAT IS A REAL FEAR EVERY
GREAT SOCIETY COLLAPSED WHEN
THEY OVEREXTENDED THEMSELVES.
WE’VE JUST PASSED FOUR BILLS
MORE THAN $2.7 TRILLION AND YOU
COMBINE THIS WITH WHAT THE FED
IS DOING, THAT’S $7 TRILLION
INTO THE ECONOMY.
LET’S FIRST LOOK AT THE RESULTS
BEFORE WE WANT TO GO BACK AND
TRY TO REWORK ANOTHER BILL.
I’D LISTEN TO THE DEMOCRATS BUT
THIS IS WHERE THEIR SOCIALISM
COMES OUT.
THEY PICK THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
BEFORE THEY EVEN KNOW WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
LET’S GET THIS IMPLEMENTED INTO
SOCIETY AND LET THE $7 TRILLION
WORK, LET’S LOOK AT RESULTS
BEFORE WE REACT TO ANYTHING ELSE
MOVING FORWARD.
MARIA: OKAY, WE’LL LEAVE IT
THERE CONGRESSMAN GREAT TO SEE
YOU THIS MORNING THANK YOU